[Music]
have y'all heard of the uh
the phrase or the the quote um [ __ ] i
already [ __ ] it up i can't remember
the quote
never mind have you heard of the quote
that i don't know it's so rememberable
that um that i have to scroll down have
you heard
okay uh every saint has had a past and
every sinner has a future what did that
mean oh i've never heard of that oh yeah
i think i think i've never heard of it
yeah
can you say can you say it one more time
because i think you said it like
try one more time every saint has a
past and every sinner has a future like
no one's innocent and whoever's
evil can change you're not you're guilty
you're guilty or you're guilty a lot of
people that say that
normally have [ __ ] up past and they're
trying to try to justify that [ __ ]
oh bad person and then all the
holier than that it's to bless your
heart sweetie
bless your heart it's basically to tell
them telling you to go to hell
oh yeah but then secretly like they have
bodies in their backyard oh yeah
right the most innocent looking people
are
probably the worst [ __ ] and you
know the most calmest people who have
gone through some [ __ ]
oh yeah because nothing really phases
them right
no anxiety people dying
been there tuesday and then now we're
talking about this guy
yes let's [ __ ] go bro i want to
launch on this pope he's like
what do you want to say he's like i've
been waiting all day for my
shot let's get it i have a problem with
all pokes actually you have a problem
with this
since the catholic church sexual [ __ ] oh
right we're like pedal pulse well he's
the first pope that's ever said anything
against him i like that part yeah
he's all like i'm not a pedal pope no
well he's just like you know what we
should be protecting the people
whoever is like actually a molester
needs to like
get taken care of something i'm i like
that i like all that i'm butchering it
but he
he is the very first pope to ever even
address trump
he's definitely changing the game
because he's what is this pope's name
john
francis yes yeah he often says like
positive things about lgbtq
community too like recently he even said
like uh something about like
you know parents should love their kids
no matter what whether or not they
decide to
you know say what their gender is later
on essentially is what he's saying yeah
it's like rather liberal i think for for
popes like in terms of the standards
that pat's past
popes have already said the the bar that
they've set
uh it's closer to how jesus sounded kind
of right
yeah more like that hatred old testament
side
i do not know pope is the car of christ
right he's the living embodiment of
christ on earth
can somebody break it down i mean when
it comes to religion i'm a little bit
not so you're like the king of catholics
yeah but then how does that work if they
choose the pope
right now is he voted on like how it's
not that he is jesus
exactly it's like he is the
representation or whatever i don't know
so but then
the car so i guess i'm trying to think
of it like in the moment you know
so that there's a guy and then they're
trying to decide if he should be pope
you know after the last one
there's a committee yeah yeah yeah they
get he gets voted and he's like
i am now the representative and i have
this connection now but beforehand
isn't that right there yeah he didn't
have the holy connection before yeah you
got to get voted to get the vote holy
he did but then the job promoted him to
have like a
slightly higher his holy points went
higher the white smoke clears the way
for the holy connection
when they make a decision there's smoke
that comes out of that chimney
it's the white smoke if he's if he's
passed or the black smoke if he's not or
some [ __ ]
you know there was a pope before him
because you remember that pope that was
around for like a long time
john paul ii and then he passed in 2005.
i remember when he passed because i was
living in mexico at that time and all of
mexico was mourning
like crazy morning when he passed and
then after that the pope that
that took the job the next the next po
yeah that guy
he only stayed for a little bit and then
he was like yeah
that's when this guy's really so you can
quit so how does that work just do they
stay is there a return
until they're dead yeah but this dude
just quit i forgot why
he got tired he's like pretty much the
only one that has quit he basically said
that he couldn't do it because of i
think he was having medical problems so
he was
oh so he wasn't
yeah so the reason why i brought up the
quote from earlier i just wanted you
guys to kind of guess what the pope
francis used to be in terms of his job
before it became a mechanic he's been a
lot of things a bartender
yeah so recently he came out and talked
about his past life goal
dancer hey closer uh and
what he said sent shock waves through
the religious community and just even
just people
dancing bodyguard a bouncer
yes he was a bouncer pope francis when
uh when growing up in argentina he's
from buenos aires
uh he yeah thank you uh he was a bouncer
at a club
that's pretty cool he checked ids and he
kicked people out so he was like
beautiful you're not cool you're cool
yeah
you could come in there's something dope
about
people that have worked in not
so glorified jobs because they
are more human than the person that's
just been in that
room like in the church their whole life
that doesn't know anything else because
you're super judgmental if you live in
your bubble and you look at anybody else
but i feel like he's like yo i already
seen that girl come in twice this week
we cool she's coming into church next
she coming in on sunday
i know she means well like like he was a
bouncer at night
and then he was like working on his uh
church
studies or whatever so he saw him at
church
it doesn't detail like whether or not he
was particularly religious at that point
in his life either
it was just so how does he get to that
position like what do you have to do
in order because i recently went into a
pope rabbit hole um
he was i don't know really random
like the random thing i heard well first
off she knew dates i'm impressed i'm
like yes what else i don't know this is
so rare usually it's him that's like on
point
no i'm [ __ ] all up but go ahead
but okay yeah so he became like he
started going to the church
in his 20 or i think when he was 33
is when he he became uh ordained
as a priest and then after that like
there is a ladder to climb
like from priest corporate ladder but
in a religious community and then from
priests he went to something and then
from that thing he went to cardinal or
something and then from that he went to
a bishop or something like that like
there's like a letter
yeah okay so that point like once you
get to the top that's when
they you're one of the contenders to be
pope and then that's when they vote
all that stuff he's lived a life like he
had a life outside of just the church
dude he probably cleaned the vomit and
[ __ ] oh he went through a lot of stuff
i've spent a lot of time in the club he
actually spent uh spent some time when
he went to rome he's
he lived in rome for a little bit and uh
he
he got a job sweeping the floors at like
random restaurants and stuff like
that was his job like basically a
janitor he was a bouncer a janitor
and then now he's pope that's crazy i
mean it's crazy to think that
someone so he's not a virgin no
probably not wait what really no i think
well in order to be
there you he's one of those popes that
he does stand
by the i forgot the terminology how
would you know
yeah something like that doesn't that
mean
you don't have to be a virgin in order
to be celebrated i don't know about
virginia
cardinals pledge to be celibate after
you enter the point yeah i think i'm
mixing it up i think i'm
getting quite a commitment because to be
a nun you have to be virgin no
or are you just celibate but i feel like
you don't go into no i think it is
celibacy i think i gotta mix up okay
yeah because that would make sense i
mean 33 years you don't you're not
committed to the church
i don't you're not living by those
people how do you live like that though
once you've
once you got laid how do you go back to
going like i
don't have to give this up for the rest
of my life it's going against your human
needs
but some people don't function the same
like why do you think a lot of people
can be in relationships for years and
talk about how they don't have
sex it's because their heart's broken or
whatever is going on mentally sometimes
not everybody's
libido yeah it's a real thing some
people just don't like to have sex so
maybe if you're willing to commit to
that it's because they haven't had sex
with me yet
he's like i will turn you out that's
right too bad you're at the market
he said i got a ring to prove it look
someone committed to it
but yeah i ain't got one ain't nobody
committing to it yet so i got some work
to do
were people saying that it was bad that
he did these things
uh it was mixed it was i think a lot of
people were very happy about his
transparency and talking about like hey
like my starting point in life was this
and
now i'm the pope and then while other
people are like you're not holy then you
know and you're not i mean like because
it seems cool in terms of like the holy
context of when people think of like
jesus
and the fact that he was a carpenter
peter the porn yeah you're the queen
hung out with the hookers and the tax
collectors
they still do that washing feet thing
that's one of the weirdest things i've
ever seen
seeing the pope watching the phoenix
people do that yeah it's pretty i
she just sent me a meme recently where
where there was a baby being dunked
to be baptized and they'd be why did
they dunk the babies
it was one of those like audio
replacement things and they had the
scene from the big lebowski where
they're done oh my god
like oh where's the [ __ ] money in the
basket where's the [ __ ] ball
where's the money [ __ ]
he's gonna look back at that video and
be like that's what y'all did to me
i ain't never going back to church
usually it's not that hard i think it's
a different
like type of i thought they just like
sprinkle water that was like
i thought they just like here cool
usually well the way
like mexican catholics we do it at one
year
is when babies get back and then they
sprinkle a little lucas on the baby's
forehead
they changed the formula they don't have
the lead anymore it's not the same all
you see is somebody going
you have you have been blessed i have
given you my holy spirit
oh could you imagine that you just been
like
what the [ __ ] sir i wouldn't i wouldn't
be surprised though because
don't we like drink the blood of jesus
communion
[Laughter]
why can't the blood of jesus be [ __ ]
tamarind vodka dude
no communion comedians bomb though you
get a little like you get welch's grape
juice it's a [ __ ]
bread it's like a grape i've never had
that bread before it's pretty good
you know why it's because you're so
hungry in church if you're not religious
learning about other people's religion
is really interesting you're like so you
drink his blood and eat his body
and then the most interesting part i
know it's not just grape juice
well for our religion
[Music]
but it is interesting when you're like
open to learning a lot about
other people and you kind of go y'all
got some similar stuff
but you know what's interesting though
if you are religious you think everybody
else is [ __ ] crazy
but you'll believe the crazy [ __ ] and
you're like i know the truth you don't
you're like seagulls are my [ __ ] gods
i don't know about you guys there's a
spaghetti monster one there's a new one
i'm getting a flying spaghetti monster i
like that that's a troll
it's a complete troll oh is it oh that's
not real nobody actually believes in the
flying
skateboard it's an atheist joke wait
wait wait wait wait wait what is what
wait wait what
what so there's a pastafarian religion
right it's called pastafarian they r
they registered as a religious group and
it's basically a troll
because like their god is the flying
spaghetti monster and all this stuff and
to like make fun of religion yeah well
it's also too
it's like um okay if you guys get a
statue somewhere of your guy
then we want to find somebody monster
next to it is it kind of to make it look
like hey you hear how ridiculous this
sounds yeah
that's what we think it's all it's also
to challenge the church and
state kind of concept so it's like we
have so much if they have special rules
we can use those special rules
okay isn't there supposed to be a
separation of church and state but it's
supposed to but it's so ingrained in
american culture that it's synonymous
yeah cause on our money it doesn't say
in god we trust
yeah yeah yeah but it's the eye yeah
it's mostly about the eye
and uh see what i'm learning i'm like
what's going on there's a lot oh he's
just [ __ ] around
no but why but why is there even a
pyramid and an eye on the money
[Music]
illuminati
[Music]
you